oh
get him some milk get him some milk
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game it is finally here
took us long enough but hey look it's
finally here i'm holding it in my hands
and today i'm going to show you how to
play show you what's inside the box and
explain the rules but of course
you guys know the rules tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last dab
that's how you play
hot ones truth or dab the game we wanted
to make a game that would be fun to play
with friends i always loved seeing
people take on the hot ones challenge at
home so what we did is we teamed up with
wilder toys and heatness to come up with
this
the official hot ones truth or dab card
game let's get into it
step one open up the box what's in the
box what's in the box
well here you can see we have 250
question cards with categories like
bff where players find out how well
their friends really know them
you have roast cards where they'll find
out what they really think of them
truth cards pop quiz cards 1up
categories
it's insane you have a mini bottle of
the last ab
all two million scoville and then you
have spoons
more about these in step two step two
what do we put the sauce on well
obviously for us here at the show
wings are the vessel of choice so might
i suggest
make your own wings and who better to
show you how than our own quarantined
cook-off
expert and buffalo native camera guy
bill
hey camera guy bill how should we make
the wings
what is up cam fam camera guy bill in
the wayne laboratory ready to cook up a
simple chicken ring recipe
for you the viewers for your hot ones
truth or dab the game game night
let's get cooking step one take your
giant jug of canola oil
and dump it into the deep fryer
bottoms up next turn your deep fryer up
to 350 degrees
now that your fryer's at 350 degrees
it's time to put your chicken wing
i'm a fan of the drums but you can also
put in flats
now that your wings are in they're going
to cook for eight minutes no more no
less
oh don't mind if i do perfect chicken
wings for a perfect game night
this is camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
crispy thanks bill well the spoons
though
they are here in case you're a hot sauce
purist if you just need to mainline it
if you just want to take it straight to
the face
or if you're lazy don't worry the box
has
a bunch of mini plastic spoons
all right step three let's get into how
to play it's pretty simple
we have these 250 question cards you'll
take turns being the host
being the players when you're the player
you get asked a question by the host and
you have a choice
answer it honestly or suffer the wrath
of the last dab once everyone in the
friend group has been the host
then we have the 1up round that's what
these white cards are all about
it's a question that everyone has to
answer and the questions are designed to
bring up the stories that we're just
trying to forget
you just keep going and going and going
until you can't take the heat anymore
all right guys ready to get down on some
truth or dab
let's do this guys this is cool we're
all we're in the same watch
all right here's the first question
what's the meanest thing you've ever
said to someone's face
well i'm not proud of this but one time
i told camera guy bill
hey bill take that camera and shove it
up your
take that shove it back up
inside your and if i don't see you get
into the
dude chill all right guys i guess it's
my turn
rank everyone in the room's job from
most to least
interesting i don't know if i can answer
that
i don't want to i don't want to hurt
anyone's feelings hey if you can't
answer the question
dab time baby i guess i'll take the dab
and
fall in the grenade for the squad fill
that spoon baby fill that spoon
clean that spoon clean that spoon
clean that spoon clean that spoon
[Music]
get him some milk get him some milk
all right ready who here will be most
successful in 10 years
rank everyone in the room well it's not
an easy question to answer fellas i see
a lot of promise in this room but you
know if i if i'm a push comes to shove
i really like what you got going on man
i think you just boom zoom straight to
the moon i think we're all gonna be
working for you someday
no offense dude he's just got it
[Music]
hey dude relax he's just answering the
question we can't all be me
well there you have it hot ones fans
truth or dab the game it's as easy as
one two three
available at shop.firstweavefeast.com
heatness.com and amazon
hot ones truth or dab the game play at
your own risk
wings not included